and today also the CDC is announcing
additional steps Americans can take to
defend against the transmission of the
virus from recent studies we know that
the transmission from individuals
without symptoms is playing a more
significant role in the spread of the
virus than previously understood so you
don't seem to have symptoms and it still
gets transferred in light of these
studies the CDC is advising the use of
non-medical cloth face covering as an
additional voluntary public health
specialist so it's voluntary you'd have
to do it they suggested for a period of
time but this is voluntary I don't think
I'm gonna be doing it but you have a lot
of ways you can look at it as follows
the CDC is recommending that Americans
were a basic cloth or fabric mask they
can be either purchased online or simply
made at home probably material that
you'd have at home these face coverings
can be easily washed or reuse I want to
emphasize that the CDC is not
recommending the use of medical grade or
surgical grade masks and we want that to
be used for our great medical people
that are working so hard and doing some
job medical protective gear must be
reserved for the frontline health care
workers who are performing those vital
services the new mask guidelines also do
not replace CDC's guidance on social
distancing including staying in your
home when possible standing at least 6
feet apart for a period of time again
we're going to all come back together
here we're going to all come back
together and practicing hand hygiene
which we should do anyway